so a lot of local businesses of course
rely on those services kate houston
stopped by local oasis which is near
charleston and las vegas boulevard as
they try to put out those last minute
orders holiday shopping is in full swing
so we've been very busy in store and
online
the team at abby wren illustration and
local oasis are preparing packages to
arrive before christmas people are still
ordering we're trying to get packages
out as fast as possible
my team we try to get every every order
out within a couple days owner abby
renzuma relies on ground shipping for
all of her online orders which typically
takes anywhere from one to eight days
although online shipments are up
significantly renzema says a majority of
them happened earlier in the holiday
shopping season for months shipping
companies warned that supply chain
issues and infrastructure problems could
create delays around the holidays
renzama says customers were listening
there's less pressure on the holidays
we're getting less emails of people
frantically looking for their packages
although wednesday is the last day usps
and fedex can guarantee ground shipments
by christmas there are other options
including express delivery if it's not
arriving on time you can print
you know maybe a picture of it wrap that
and tell them that it's on their way
and i'm sure people don't mind getting a
little something after the holidays kate
houston live local now